é um prazer estar aqui com vocês
principalmente pra falar de coisas que
eu adoro que são as histórias à leitura
e à arte e como será que isso pode mudar
e transformar nossa universidade ea
sociedade como um todo
primeiro quero começar a contar pra
vocês uma história ea história do meu
nome
lúcia não pensem vocês que foi tão fácil
assim escolher tudo começou com meu pai
com a minha mãe que resolveram se casar
e ter filhos e o primeiro filho que eles
tiveram foi uma menina e pra ela ea mãe
deu o nome de olívia em homenagem à avó
paterna mas com minha mãe gostava muito
de nome composto e gostava de nossa
senhora deu nome ela de olívia maria
depois minha mãe ficou grávida pela
segunda vez e era um menino então ela
deu nome a ele de francisco em homenagem
ao meu pai e meu avô paterno
mas acho que naquela época a minha mãe
também era fã de roberto carlos e
colocou o nome de francisco carlos
nasceu o terceiro filho era uma menina
christmann mas cristina maria não
combina então inverteu maria cristina
agora vocês devem estar perguntando que
horas que eu nasci ainda não calma
depois veio a cláudia cláudia maria e
finalmente chegou a minha vez só que a
minha mãe já não aguentava mais tanta
menina que tinha certeza que ela estava
grávida de um menino e já tinha até nome
pra mim eu ia me chamar andré luis
só que naquela época não tinha outra
solução a fia a minha mãe tem 92 anos
então vocês vêem que faz tempo e quando
nascia melhor não tem um nome pra ela
não a ela olhou para minha avó e pediu
para que minha avó me desse um nome e
minha avó era devota de nossa senhora de
fátima e nossa senhora de fátima foi
vista por três crianças
francisco já sim
a ilustre a e até hoje eu agradeço a
escolha da minha avó
agora vocês vão querer saber se o que é
isso gente sem preconceito leitura sem
preconceito agora vocês vão querer saber
se o andré luiz nasceu nasceu tempo
depois veio o andré luis e assim a mãe
meu pai fechar a fábrica
as aulas podem começar assim propondo os
alunos que falem dos seus nomes e as
histórias que moram dentro deles são
tantas
depois eu peço para que eles me contem
como foi a sua experiência na biblioteca
e eles me contam histórias terríveis
algumas bibliotecas é um lugar de
castigo pra mim nunca foi assim como
borges
eu acredito que o paraíso é uma espécie
de biblioteca e essa foi a primeira
biblioteca que eu conhecia a biblioteca
da minha escola e foi ali que eu
encontrei um livro que eu me apaixonei
o primeiro que eu li ning joão bolinha
virou gente vicente guimarães também
conhecido como vovô felício eu gostei
tanto dessa história que vivi com ela
uma felicidade clandestina assim como no
conto de clarice lispector e eu não quis
devolvê lo mas o prazo quando eu vi a
multa é enorme
aí eu pensei que a bibliotecária nem da
falta do livro
mal sabia eu que anos depois e estudar
biblioteconomia e me tornar uma
bibliotecária e saber exatamente onde o
livro estaria e foi o que aconteceu
minha mãe foi me matricular na escola e
quando chegou recebeu uma carta da
bibliotecária cobrando livre e quando a
minha mãe chegou em casa ela disse lo se
á quando ela falava assim eu gelava
porque eu sabia que tinha feito alguma
coisa porque senão ela losing a filhinha
lua e aí ela me disse que a
bibliotecária tava querendo um livro que
não tinha devolvido e aí eu contei para
ela a história da multa a história do
amor entre eu e ele mas não adiantou
minha mãe disse resolve isso e na semana
seguinte quando a aula começou eu fui
falar com a bibliotecária e ela me deu
duas
opções a primeira era pagar a multa e
ficar o ano inteiro sem manchar ea
segunda era ficar seis meses sem
freqüentar a biblioteca
eu escolhi a primeira opção hoje pra mim
um livro sempre valeu mais do que um
pacote de biscoito e é isso que eu falo
para os meus alunos é preciso descobrir
o valor da leitura
qual é a leitura que comove que te
prende que te pega
algumas pessoas dizem para mim mas como
eu faço para formar um leitor
e eu respondo começa a conversar e
descobre que ele gosta porque entre um
mediador de leitura e seus leitores
precisa haver diálogo às vezes é desse
diálogo não é tão fácil assim
uma vez numa aula eu descobri que um
aluno não gostava nada de ler ele não
interagia vivia com aquele olhar parado
e um dia eu arrisquei cheguei perto dele
e perguntei e e aí gostou da história e
ele respondeu ah eu tentei mais um pouco
mas naquela hora é que a vizinha ouviu
aquele barulho você acreditava que era o
personagem que tinha feito aquilo era
uma história de terror
ele disse eu não continue mais um pouco
de todas as histórias que eu contei que
você gostou mais
e ele me respondeu não me lembro não
desistir do leitor mas resolvi para a
conversa e comecei a observar ele todos
os dias e percebi que ele era um leitor
de silêncios e também de sons eles
amavam os sons da natureza e trouxe
vários livros pra ele que falavam sobre
o mar
a cachoeira a chuva eo logo percebi que
em telhe os livros nascia uma história
de amor
por isso precisamos
os respeitar os leitores porque cada um
é de um jeito
alguns nem de tudo outros lêem muito
pouco
outros devagar quase parando e até
desistem e tem ainda aqueles que estão
procurando por livros que procuram por
eles
isso me lembra um conto de eduardo
galeano que diz que o mundo visto de
cima são como pequenas fogueiras linhas
cada um de nós tem seu brilho próprio
somos fogueiras pequenas fogueiras
grandes cada um queima do seu jeito
isso não importa o que importa é queimar
assim também são os nossos leitores um
isqueiro mon outros não queimam nunca e
outros ainda vão queimar o que importa
em incendiar
quando me fazem outra pergunta assim mas
o que nós devemos contar e como contar
eu digo escolha alguma história que mexe
com você que faz você quebrar esse é o
primeiro passo
depois pensa no cenário nos personagens
lembra que o teu corpo também fala que
tua voz têm ritmos e que a história é
uma cadência como uma música e lembra
que o olhar diz muita coisa
depois é só ser natural e deixar falar o
coração quando eu falo para os meus
alunos assim então e vamos contar uma
história e eles mesmo onde há não ainda
não estou preparado tenho vergonha
aí eu mudo a pergunta você contaria pra
alguém que há muito não move a palavra
nem o sorriso de ninguém
e aí eles resolvem contar e escolhemos
músicas que contam histórias e são
tantas
eu escolhi a primeira felicidade de
lupicínio rodrigues e canto felicidade
fui embora e em saudade no meu peito
tu ainda mora e é por isso que eu gosto
lá de fora porque sei que a falsidade
não vigora e eu me lembro de uma
história que também fala sobre
felicidade da autora roseana murray e
diz
felicidade é frágil borboleta mas sempre
se recompõe semente mágica em novo
casulo e assim os alunos escolhem suas
músicas e suas histórias
nada é proibido tudo é permitido
as escolhas são deles e assim eles
descobrem que a palavra sedução e que
palavra nenhuma anda sozinha uma palavra
tem a força de me curar mas também de me
ferir
por isso contamos cantamos e por vezes
escrevemos escrever pra mim às vezes me
dói começa com uma vontade louca e tem
logo vontade de terminar e quando
termino tô cansada
parece que corri uma maratona outras
vezes me sinto leve como uma pluma e
digo para os meus alunos escrevam vamos
escrevam escrevam para esvaziar seus
pensamentos na universidade se cobra tão
tanto a escrita mas para escrever é
preciso ter uma motivação e eu falo pra
ele façam perguntas façam perguntas
encontram encontrem respostas eu faço
perguntas pra eles e fiz uma pergunta
encontrei as respostas deles e queria
compartilhar com vocês
a pergunta era como você como você vê a
universidade como você se sente
quais suas sugestões para uma
reconstrução e eles me responderam mais
segurança e menos violência e mais tempo
para viver
estamos cansados mais união - racismo
preconceito e abuso de poder
se olharmos com atenção para as
respostas deles podemos perceber que
elas são sim
dia de sentimentos e emoções e que as
respostas deles também são pedidos
nossos eles desejam uma colheita farta e
duradoura e por que não podemos
encontrar um caminho através da leitura
das histórias a reconstruir essa
universidade e as pessoas que caminham
por ela e que não só o corpo docente
decente mas quem forma um todo também
talvez estamos desejando mais leveza
onde tudo precisa ser leve e mais
compromisso onde temos que ter a alegria
tome conta de nós que o conteúdo seja
denso mas também tem emoção para que
possamos vivenciar e que essa alegria
tome conta de nós no dia-a-dia da
universidade
mesmo que seja com tarefas difíceis mas
que são possíveis como nos diz o autor
desse livro feliz na universidade
ele fala podemos aprender com alegria e
não só com o sofrimento a vida na
universidade pode ser um período de
florescimento cultural e não somente
restrições a serem suportadas
eu penso que às vezes vivemos aqui
dentro um isolamento cada um fazendo o
seu mas é preciso fazer o todo costurar
a colcha de retalhos e por que não e
quem sabe fazendo outras perguntas como
porque muitos desistem e outros adoecem
a leitura a arte ea cultura podem mudar
isso
eu creio que sim a leitura arte ea
cultura podem mudar sim porque ela
permite ao indivíduo escrever um pedaço
da sua história
e pra terminar eu gosto das perguntas
porque as dúvidas
me movimento eu não tenho certezas e
termino a minha fala com essas três
perguntas
mergulhar em uma história pode
transformar a pintar um quadro próprio
admite transportar por um cenário do que
estou pintando inscrever pode me fazer
lembrar de coisas essenciais que estavam
esquecidas
eu acho que sim e porque vocês não
começam a tentar comecem com o nome de
vocês
o primeiro presente que a gente recebe e
assim vocês podem começar a escrever a
sua história que possamos romper com um
mito um mito de que a aprendizagem está
ligado ao sofrimento abraçando outras
formas de aprender que nos torne mais
felizes criativos e interessantes muito
obrigada